and then we got some tennis you said you
want to talk about the 10 i know you're
a big tennis fan i'm not a big tennis
fan you are no i i wish i was and you
guys
if you're a man that follows tennis at
all you're a big fan okay then i'm a big
tennis player tennis is basically is
baseball to me yeah i think
it's not as bored but it is a girl sport
it's because people are actual athletes
like tennis is for women these people
are actual like they're actually playing
a sport where baseball you stand there
you're running they're not really
athletes they're just like rich people
and then finally two poor people joined
the sport and they just dominated for
the last [ __ ] 20 years
actually you know one of them wasn't
poor only one of them might have been
poor maybe venus and serena were related
is the only one that's interesting no
dude i'm telling you if you are a fan of
greatness yeah this is the coolest time
in maybe any sport ever
the three greatest of all time are
playing right now in any sport if that
was happening you'd be like you have to
appreciate this i'm not montana i'm not
a big fan of tennis right now but this
is the best time to watch no this is oh
is this what i felt like in the
beginning of the pocket
is this what it felt like it's really
interesting the most boring thing this
is actually interesting so why are you
closeted
why are tennis why is because if you're
watching actually interesting it's far
less impressive
getting a [ __ ] yellow ball over a net
yeah yeah but the three greatest of all
time are doing it right now at the same
time oh
oh my god if you lose a tennis ball
if you lose a rhino match if he was a
ronald magic dead
he's taking baby cubs ain't nothing
gonna happen yeah yeah yeah yeah okay go
back to your little uh
the three greatest of all time
are playing at the same time if you're
watching like all this [ __ ] we're like i
would love to see uh how great are they
i would love to see montana and brady
you know lead football how great like
give me an example how great are they so
you have tournaments like uh
championships basically yeah the
greatest of all time before had 14. okay
there are now three guys with 20 each so
neither of them is that great
no they're the three greatest of all
average yeah but they're just like equal
no one's dominant like you're basically
looking at the least dominant time in
tennis and you're looking at the most
the least dominant it's the least
dominant there's three people all
dominating the same you got a tie you've
got three [ __ ] bronze medals 128
people discover your bronze 128 people
enter every tournament one of the same
three has won pretty much every time for
the last 18 years yeah so nobody's
dominant yeah the most dominant time in
the history of any sport is right now
how do you define
players one person tying all the time
there's three players well they're not
tied
three people are tied they're twenty you
got yeah go back and forth that's like
having five championships and five
championships they're not tying in the
nba fight neither of those teams are
dominant so the celtics weren't dominant
the lakers weren't dominant if they did
it in other teams one the bulls did when
the bulls in a row they were dominant
but if you're going back and forth with
another team neither is dominant
that's the least dominant time in
history dominant runs at least all the
time
but keep understanding why you need to
do this oh yeah
[Applause]
i would i would get in on this because
it is kind of exciting yeah but i have
to cut your legs most dominant times in
the history of tennis yeah yeah most
dominant time of men who wear like wrist
guards yes yeah absolutely yeah they
wear wrist guards oh it's sweaty and
it's the greatest of all time
now yeah so it's sweat in the eye that's
difficult bro yeah yeah you guys are
gonna sway in the eye
you know how much effort you got to do
in a grunt
that's mad efforts that's true
130 miles per hour i think you could
trap a rhino with his surf that's your
answer yeah hold on kill a rhino
[Laughter]
he could kill a velociraptor with this
there's no
in my chest a tennis ball would not hurt
me
100 seriously 10 as well to the chest
wouldn't hurt me we may have a gun that
can shoot a tennis ball at the speed of
a gun
no no no the t-shirt got back
from a tennis racket is different than
130 miles from a gun what do you mean
it's like spiders it's the same thing
it's a 230 bucks
it's the ball density the ball density
is far greater when you're hitting off a
little bit
i think we should get this i think
i think we should go
let's get the gun it goes listen i don't
believe it let's get the guy
no it doesn't have it doesn't have the
sauce it doesn't have the sauce does it
not what a shampoo what a shame and we
can't buy it because you can't put on
plants anyway go go go we'll do it at
one of the shows it'll be great great
celebration keep on going talk about the
least dominant time in tennis in history
so the most dominant time in the history
of any sport is right now do you love it
because it's just white people
is it is it you just love watching white
athleticism yeah i do enjoy it i do
enjoy white excellence there's not
enough of it in sports i do personally
like to see them for the underdog
what is it
novak djokovic novak djokovic roger
federer
what rafael nadal raphael de nil nadal
you watch f1 so you know all about
europeans i love formula one shout outs
to daniel ricardo winning monza shout
outs to team mclaren and that's all talk
about orlando norris i love you all man
keep killing it okay so as a guy who
loves europeans you should like tennis
yeah yeah no he likes romans he likes
romans yeah i mean djokovic isn't from
europe dude and like the crazy thing no
he's not from europe the crazy thing the
three people that are so dominant all
three of them lost
yeah they lost
about yeah so so none of them were
dominant enough to win the [ __ ]
tournament they're all in this
tournament and got beat they got your
[ __ ] he's looking at you so crazy
yeah
even the girls right this is something
like uh [ __ ] filipino girl yeah
dude it's poker
yeah poker is a [ __ ] he takes massive
skills no it's not a coin
between three people because poker you
know all three of them lost yeah all
three of them lost right there losers
only one of them played in this
tournament
they couldn't even qualify i thought you
just said all three were the tournaments
they couldn't qualify
what injury could you possibly get just
doing that tennis elbow that's all it's
a [ __ ] cervical diagnosis
from swatting you swat for a living dog
yeah if you kill the fly you can play
tennis 100 percent dude you watch people
drive sad you watch people drive how do
you watch that's only impressive to a
new yorker this how do you watch
football this was so much more
impressive than any football okay so go
back to your own impressive outside of
tom brady yeah no football player
impresses me as much as what's happening
in tennis right now okay explain it i
just did
that was it yeah yeah that was the most
impressive thing
one lost and then some random [ __ ]
this period from 2003 until now there
have been 72 uh majors these three have
won 60 of them
everybody else is just in there they
come they go one guy will get one here
there yesterday a guy got one i don't
know if he's gonna be good for that long
he could be but the same three people
for the past 18 years have dominated
this sport and then they go back and
forth all the time on who's gonna get
the record for the most championships
ever and it's just a [ __ ] incredible
thing to watch and it's almost over two
of the guys are dumb old so it's almost
over and you should just enjoy if you
watch greatness and appreciate greatness
just watch tennis right now and enjoy it
who's great
graphite on the doll but which one of
them is great all three of the greatest
of all time
are you sure that like athletes haven't
found real sports and then this is just
what's left and they're like these are
like the mediocre guys that are all
fighting for me could you beat the doll
if i could beat him not on clay he's
good on clay
i don't believe in playing on clay like
why are we switching the bottoms up like
yeah why don't you front the money and
then put the [ __ ] grass well it's
like a racetrack i could beat him at
wimbledon
you could not beat him at wimbledon i
could beat him at wimbledon not
wimbledon no chance
yeah he beat roger federer at wimbledon
yeah but roger federer is 75 years old
he's from no roger federer in his prime
roger federer is a swiss [ __ ]
he's a swiss [ __ ] i have a problem
anytime he feels a little bit of
adversity he just falls you bend that
man right over that's what i said that's
not true he's a swiss [ __ ] no he's not
he's not he's that's what's [ __ ] he's
a swiss [ __ ] or swiss guy he's a swiss
[ __ ] he's a swiss [ __ ] what about
nothing what about the doll say what in
the doll he's a spanish cook
but he's left-handed
like just hit it to his other hand
dude this is so easy
no you know what you know how fast he is
he just runs around the backhand makes
it a forehand
not when i hit it to him
he doesn't have a backhand i just hit
him through his backhand done game over
this is light work why don't they just
try to hit him with the serve and then
debilitate them like a rhino that's a
good idea don't they just do that
that's so powerful exactly they will
kill rhinoceros all three of them with
their bare hands with their bare hands
can't do it with their bearing to it
wrap it on the doll faster than a tiger